[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 26th of
may i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
now on to the show
the sioux gray report came out yesterday
boris johnson looks to be in the clear
and the chancellor has unveiled a big
spending package to address the cost of
living crisis katie balls and james
forsyth will join me
ann williams writes in this week's cover
piece about the new front line taiwan
what lessons has taiwan learn from the
war in ukraine he'll be on the show with
emma ashford we'll have a sneak preview
of tomorrow's women with balls episode
katie ball speaks to francis haugen the
facebook whistleblower
and finally rod little will be on the
show is technology ruining our attention
spans
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord genuity wealth
management who are sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes canaccord are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who go above and beyond to offer you
support and guidance just visit can do
wealth dot com to find out more
now first up sucre has finally published
a report into number 10's lockdown
parties how damning were her findings
and what's boris johnson's plan to move
the story on i'm joined now by james
forsyth our political editor and katie
balls our deputy political editor
james and katie thanks so much for
joining me so it's been a big week in
westminster first of course sue gray
finally dropped her report into the
lockdown parties happening in downing
street james can you tell us a bit
what's in the 37 pages uh that we've had
to read and what they mean for the prime
minister
it's a fairly grim compendium of the
events that took place in downing street
in the cabinet office that shouldn't
have taken place uh during the various
covid lockdowns there are messages from
martin reynolds boris's principal
private sector at the time talking about
you know i think we got away with it
about a a gathering in the
garden it is a fairly unedifying list
you know there are there are people
drinking too much and being sick there's
a minor altercation
but what it does not contain i think is
any
uh
new revelation that has put the skids
under boris johnson i think and i think
that is why
uh
you know 24 hours on from the
publication of his report
we've only seen three more three new
tory mps come out calling for boris
johnson to go
yes katie it feels like while some of
the report is utterly damning into the
behavior happening inside downing street
during lockdown uh the prime minister
seems to have yet again gotten away with
it
well i think it's partly because this
report has been a long time in the
making so what does the report tell us
that people haven't already heard some
semblance of and therefore there are
embarrassing details james just outlined
some i think the one passage that's
particularly worrying tory mps is this
idea that cleaning staff were treated
badly by number 10 um political
officials um in that sense
and then also just details such as a
number 10 staff are leaving past 4 am
not because they were working late um
but because they were drinking and
partying
and then also you add things such as um
ahead of that um
uh bring your own booze garden party
uh a message went around suggesting that
given this press conference was just
wrapping up telling people not to
socialize people should be a bit careful
and refrain from waving bottles of wine
around so all these things bring more
color to it but i think generally
speaking there's not really you know a
sense of a new event a new thing which
um changes it there's some questions of
whether there's a bit of a cover-up
going on in the sense that the alleged
downing street flat party
which is uh said you know aids that they
heard um abba music playing the night
the dominant cummings left um from the
dining street flat that actually wasn't
really investigated in any great detail
and i think there are some questions
about that but
so i think a few of the a few things
which have made people feel i mean are
very uncomfortable and of course a
trickle of people calling for boris
johnson to go that could become
something you know you don't know when
you could hit that um
54 letters by which you get a confidence
vote but i think in a way had this
report come out in january or february
perhaps it would have been the final
nail in the coffin for boris johnson but
because it has been pushed and pushed i
think the prime minister has used that
time fairly effectively in terms of
shoring up his position with tory mps
and that he was in a uh a more uh secure
position when it when it came out i
don't think he's out of the woods yet
but it definitely feels right now as
though this is not uh something which is
going to lead to the end of his
premiership at this stage
now james the chancellor uh in the
commons today has announced a huge new
support package to help people with the
cost of living crisis 15 billion pounds
of new spending in total uh we know he's
been planning on announcing something
for some time so it's not to say that
this is linked to this uk report one
might note the timing is slightly
interesting however um can you talk us
through a bit about what the chancellor
has announced
yeah so there is 400 pounds for every
household and then there is a enhanced
support of 650 pounds for the 8 million
most vulnerable households and what that
essentially means is that for those
households the government is ascent it
is when you add all the various packages
together picking up for them the the
vast majority of the increase in energy
costs
and it is more generous than simply
upgrading benefits would have been
how are they paying for this well the
whole the package isn't fully funded but
the biggest funding mechanism involved
is uh what they are calling an excess
profits levy i in otherwise known as a
windfall tax
and that raises over five billion pounds
on oil and gas companies uh and that
raises over five billion pounds that
means it's raising more than twice what
uh labour's windfall tax is aiming to
raise now this is obviously going to be
the most controversial element of the
package in uh tory circles there will be
uh you know uh
intellectual economists who who don't
like it i i think i think what the
justification for it is is is twofold
really
one is that uh these profits are not
coming from something that the companies
have done they've not they've not
increased a more innovative way of of
extracting oil and gas
these profits are a result of vladimir
putin's invasion of ukraine and what
that has done to european regional
energy prices
and i think then i think the second
argument is this is that this sector is
not a sector that is a stranger to
government intervention uh you had
government support packages uh in in the
early part of the 2010s when the north
sea looked like it was in danger of
becoming uneconomic because of because
of low energy prices so i think once you
once you have got an appeal to
government for support in one case it's
quite hard to then argue against a
windfall tax in another case i want to
come back to the windfall taxes but
first katie james talks about some of
the support there and if you are one of
the eight million most vulnerable
households in the uk you're looking at a
direct cash top-up of over 1 000 pounds
this year i think it's roughly 1 200.
that's roughly on par with a joe biden
stimulus check now if we go back to
february one of the criticisms against
the chancellor was that his support
package wasn't going far enough he said
at the time i can't do everything to
ease these burdens i can just play a
role he said again today i can't take
away all the pain i can just play a role
how long is it before we you think we
hear requests for more funding more
support packages or do you think this
will actually um address many of the
criticisms that people have had over the
past few months
look i'm sure there'd be calls today
when it comes to requests for more help
because as you say
um this is not going to completely take
away the pain there are lots of people
who are still going to be struggling and
therefore i think you will see people
saying oh does this go far enough does
it go in the right way is this the best
way to do it um
it's not just energy bills which are one
of the problems here in terms of
people's personal finances look at how
food prices are expected to soar and but
i think in terms of i suppose uh where
richie sooner goes from here i think he
was definitely vulnerable to the
criticism that when it comes to the
worst off in society
and not enough had been provided in the
spring statement and you had rishi sunex
saying well i couldn't do much in terms
of universal credit uplift even if i
wanted to because of the computer system
everyone said is that a real reason the
computer system um but i think you're
seeing them trying to address that and
that is the main thrust today
when it comes to the packages i think
there is a general issue for richie
sunett which goes back also to the
windfall tax which is amongst tory mps
there is no i think universal agreement
uh of what rishi sunex should be doing
so there will be some tory mps pretty
aghast at the windfall tax they think it
is unconservative they are ideologically
opposed it could be a slippery slope
what does this do in terms of the
message of sending business there are
others who are very pro in full tax and
have been pushing for us probably i
would say more mps than not um that
and the tory party support are windfall
tax and often the quieter ones broadly
because they want to look as though
they're doing something on cost of
living
um and and therefore i think rishi
senior is going to face critic criticism
no matter what he does and that includes
within his own party
james riccicinek has been very keen to
know that there's going to be a sunset
clause in this wonderful tax legislation
so that when oil prices return to
something more historically normal the
winfield tax goes he's been keen to note
that it's rather generous although that
feels like a strange word to you so
we're talking about tax hikes on
investment that the more business uh
decides to invest back into the company
uh the less tax they'll be paying
through this levy um regardless though
does this not open up pandora's box
what about the supermarkets that did
very well in lockdown what about the
streaming services if government
realizes that its tax rate can actually
be quite successful in getting the money
into the treasury's coffers why would
they stop at energy companies and what
would it mean if it weren't a tory
government in charge but perhaps a labor
government or coalition that would be
very keen to go further on some kind of
tax rate
so i i mean i mean something
distinguishes uh the energy companies
from the supermarkets which is yes in
the the supermarkets during the pandemic
some of the competition rules were
relaxed to allow them to coordinate more
in terms of keeping shops stocked and
the like but the supermarkets are the
supermarket sector in the uk is highly
competitive it doesn't come to
government for support or bailouts or or
or other kinds of forms of financial
assistance and i mean that makes it a
very different category uh i mean i
think that is the distinction here and
katie what does this mean for the
chancellor professionally and on some
level personally uh he became known
throughout the cove pandemic as the one
who was going to give away all the money
give all the handouts uh this is another
form of handout although admittedly
times have been a lot tougher and he's
also had to be the person holding back
those cash splashes uh do you think that
this is going to be good for brand rishi
as it's so often called
i i think for being honest it's just a
bit too hard to tell in the sense that i
think the cost of living crisis means
that so many people feel as though they
are finding it hard to make ends meet
that lots of people think that well
finally you're doing something even if
they welcome it and therefore i don't
think this is going to lead to you know
a big bout of rishi
mania um and then and also on one side
you've got um plenty on the tory side
who are questioning uh well this is the
right policy i think it's interesting if
you look at the number 10 number 11
dynamic because over the past week or so
quite a publicly a debate was playing
out where you had senior members of
boris johnson's team figures such as
david canzini one of his deputy chiefs
of staff and arguing against us which is
why we had quite a strange situation
when we look back on it of an opposition
day debate where tory mps voted against
the idea of a windfall tax now the
tories will say oh well it was a
slightly different windfall tax there
weren't the details that we have now but
i think does just reflect how the
government itself has not been able to
decide on this course of action very
easily
and but i think if we're looking for the
big winner when it comes to today's
announcements it's probably labor
labor's clearest policy i think has been
a winful tax they've called for it
repeatedly and you can say this is uh
different what it does for investment
make those arguments but at the end of
the day when labour are trying to say to
voters you can trust us on the economy
one of their biggest weak points and
historically if you look at recent
elections particularly
is they can say well the tories use
their ideas i think that definitely
plays into this idea that
labour are not you know this outlier on
the economy which the tories often want
to depict them as when it comes to
election campaigns
katie and james thanks for joining me
in this week's cover piece spectator
contributor ann williams writes from
taiwan he says the country is learning
lessons from the war in ukraine to
explain anne joins me now alongside emma
ashford at the scowcroft center
and you write in your cover piece for
the spectator magazine this week that
taiwan has been watching the war in
ukraine very closely tell us why
i think because it's very close to home
a number of people said to me
geographically it's very it's a very
long way away but in every other respect
it's chillingly close
and i think there are a number of
reasons for that
they see
in this idea of a of a big powerful
um neighbor wanting to quash a democracy
driven by an idea of restoring empire
and also
one which has partnered with china
across across the strait they see a lot
in common with that and i think that
you've seen a grey war play out against
taiwan for a number of years now and for
a lot of taiwanese this was almost
background noise yes there were cyber
attacks there was different
disinformation there was intimidation by
jets and ships but it was always seen as
something they kind of lived with and
a lot of people didn't think it would
ever come to
open hostilities and i think it's come
home to them it's been a real wake-up
call the violence the invasion uh in
ukraine particularly as it seemed to be
to a lot of people irrational a lot of
people thought putin wouldn't do it in
the same way a lot of people has been
have been saying that she wouldn't do it
because it's not a rational thing to do
and i think a lot of people are saying
well she and putin they're on the same
wavelength they're not necessarily
rational actors
emma there are now comparisons between
russia's attack on ukraine and a
potential attack on taiwan by the
chinese communist party how do you think
the two situations might be different
yeah so i mean obviously as ian said
there are these parallels um but the
parallels are mostly at this sort of
large strategic geopolitical sense um
that there are also some some major
differences that i think are worth
bearing in mind here um and one is that
even prior to february 24th of this year
um ukraine and russia were actually
engaged in a conflict right so this
conflict goes back at least as far as
2014 there's been this disputed
territory in the east of ukraine um in
contrast the chinese communist party's
approach to taiwan in recent decades
while they are clearly still trying to
exert influence and pull taiwan further
into their sort of speed of influence it
has been primarily economic and so you
know it would be a shift i think if
china were to start pursuing military
options towards taiwan um and that's not
how russia has been approaching this
problem so so there are these
differences and i think we should be
cautious we can certainly draw lessons
from the ukraine case but we should be
cautious about assuming they are exactly
the same
and what do you make of emma's points
and i'm also wondering if you could tell
us a bit about the importance of taiwan
to xi
i think that the recovery as he would
put it of taiwan is very much central to
his rejuvenation of the chinese nation
his his broader
ideology his broader sense of the
chinese dream and and here there are
parallels with with putin's ruski
with his idea of the russian world these
are both
imperial visions of the restoration of
empire um an important difference of
course is that taiwan is an island which
makes any sort of invasion any military
operation far more challenging than it
does across a land border but i think
one of the things that was most striking
to me in my visit to taiwan
was how people were taken by the
resilience of the ukrainians and how
they managed to push back against a far
better equipped and apparently stronger
force
now a lot of people see parallels there
between china and taiwan
in that that has been around for a while
in taiwan this
military strategy asymmetric sometimes
dub the porcupine strategy which
emphasize the use of smarter technology
the use of smaller mobile more resilient
arms whether they're
smart mines or drones or precision
missiles
and this debate has been going on for
some time and it's been urged and pushed
along by the americans but suddenly
they're seeing this in action in ukraine
suddenly they're seeing an asymmetric
war suddenly they're seeing what
resilience can do
and how strong the western backing has
been which came as a shock i think in
beijing and also a surprise in taiwan so
this is shifting the debate quite
considerably in taiwan over the future
of their own defense
and emma joe biden made a big
intervention this week seemingly
committing the us to defending taiwan
militarily how does this change things
yeah so this is about the third or
fourth time that joe biden has made this
exact gaffe um you know misstating
the us government's position on taiwan
policy and i think at this point you
know you really can't call it a gaffe
this is clearly what the president
believes um
i i think this is quite worrying um
because the u.s has long pursued a
policy of strategic ambiguity towards
taiwan that is to say we we sell the
taiwanese arms sometimes we even
intervene if we feel the chinese are
getting too aggressive if you remember
the taiwan strait incident back in the
1990s where the clinton administration
sailed some carriers through the taiwan
strait as a signal to beijing but we've
always maintained that ambiguity and
that flexibility
and i think you know if the
administration is indeed moving towards
some form of
clarity that the u.s will in fact
actually defend taiwan um i think that's
a little worrying because it shifts us
from a world where we're talking about
porcupine strategies arming the
taiwanese deterring the chinese it
shifts us much more into a world where
we're talking about setting ourselves up
for a potential u.s china conflict
rather than this more sort of hands-off
arming approach that we've taken in
ukraine
and do you think biden was wise to
say yet again that he was uh going to
back the tie at the taiwanese with his
with the us military and how have these
remarks been received in taiwan and
indeed china well he may have actually
inadvertently added to the ambiguity
because of course he he uh he rode back
somewhat or the white house rode back
somewhat on it as they have done
in the past but certainly in taiwan
they're very cautious about comments
like this
because
and numerous conversations i had they're
really stressing that they need to be
able to demonstrate that they are
willing and able to defend themselves um
they're aware that there have been
observers in the states that say
why should we commit further to the
defense of taiwan when they appear not
to be sufficiently willing to come to
their own defense and i think one of the
things that's emerged from the uk crisis
is
a sense of civic pride that has emerged
polls showing that
record numbers of youngsters are willing
to stand up and defend their own country
and i think that
in pushing them about
what biden has been saying and the
american position
i think privately they would welcome it
but publicly they're very cautious about
that and they want to be seen to be
capable of looking after themselves and
i think that one of their greatest means
of defense
as they see it is in fact their
democratic system because they would
argue that it's very difficult for a
country which
shares the values of western democracy
and
is so critical to international supply
chains high-tech chips
it would be very difficult for other
western democrat democracies to ignore
any hostility against them but whether
that is military intervention or whether
it is more
ukraine-style support with an
international coalition imposing
sanctions and providing arms and backing
um that's something really that they
won't but they wouldn't really or they
prefer not to be drawn on
emma the us had been shifting its focus
away from europe in the middle east to
the indo-pacific but does the war in
ukraine potentially put the brakes on
that shift or do biden's comments about
taiwan suggest the us is going to try to
do it all
you know i i think it's notable that the
administration is coming back to talking
about asia i think it may have been
yesterday actually was 90 days since the
the invasion of ukraine um and i think
it's notable that we have seen this
resurgence the administration is now
talking about asia they released their
their indo-pacific economic strategy
such as it is um and so you know there
is this clear determination within the
administration to continue focusing on
china despite everything that's happened
in europe in the last couple of months
however i think you know that is limited
um because there are limits on what the
us is going to be able to do so long as
we are maintaining a hundred thousand
troops in eastern europe um so long as
we are you know spending much of our
sort of military-industrial capital in
arming ukraine um and so you know i i do
think the administration at some point
is going to have to make a choice
um about whether they're going to
prioritize um a focus on asia or whether
like the obama administration before
them they're basically going to get
sucked into another conflict and they're
just going to leave everything in asia
on the back burner again
and and what about the lessons that the
west is learning uh russia's attack on
ukraine has made many people worried
about food supply and getting wheat
storages out of ukraine you write in
your piece this week that 90 of the
world's top end microchips are made in
taiwan
is the u.s is the west more generally
thinking about stockpiling thinking
about preparing for potential future
conflicts that limit their access to
supply i think they are doing that i
mean it's interesting that there's a
joke that's doing the rounds in taiwan
that if the missiles start coming in was
the safest place to hide and the answer
comes a chip factory
because they would they're too valuable
to be attacked well i'm not sure about
that but certainly i think that in the
last two years
the world has woken up to the strategic
importance of of taiwan particularly to
the chip industry and particularly
in top end ships and in fact some of
those factories are
being moved this was a new one moving to
the states they're looking at europe
japan but again
taiwan sees this as an important part of
its defense and they are in no hurry to
move their top-end chip production out
of taiwan because they do see it as a
shield as a means of defense alongside
the island's democracy
and my last question to you uh since
covert 19 hit the rhetoric from both
republicans and democrats in the states
on china has become increasingly hawkish
do you expect that to stay the same over
the next few years and if we were to see
the ccp make its moves on taiwan
do you think that they would unite in a
similar way that they've done around
ukraine
i do think that we're going to see a
continuation of the more hawkish
rhetoric in the states um you know the
the secretary of state is going to make
a speech
over the next few days in which he's
going to outline a strategy for the
administration on china that the
administration itself has characterized
as a continuation of trump's policies
towards china um there is very little
daylight between republicans and
democrats on this question um it's
mostly um a question of degree right to
what extent are they going to engage in
trade wars versus trying to open up
trade in the region to what extent are
they going to engage in direct military
alliances versus something like the quad
that's more hands-off so this is all a
question of degree and i i do think that
that is going to continue um for the
foreseeable future
um where we are more likely to see
movement um between the parties is in
fact on the questions of european
security you know we've seen a large
block in the republican side of the
island congress talking about you know
dialing down support for ukraine
focusing on asia um and so i think
actually it's going to be in non-asian
theaters that we're going to see the
change in u.s foreign policy over the
next few years
emma and eon thanks for joining me
in the upcoming women with balls episode
katie ball speaks to francis haugen the
facebook whistleblower haugen quit the
company last year and took with her
thousands of internal documents
the files she alleges show facebook knew
its products were damaging to teenagers
mental health and were fermenting ethnic
violence in countries like ethiopia
here's a preview of their discussion
now as i mentioned the introduction you
are a whistleblower so at what point
then you're obviously becoming very
uncomfortable with the things you're
seeing you've been moved off of this
um and i've i would presume from what
you're saying that when you moved off
were you frustrated to be moved off well
i i that that that wasn't why i came
forward my decision to come forward
happened a full year later so and and in
some ways we got escalated on to
you know in some ways a just as scary a
thing right like when misinformation is
targeted people like police like we
don't want the people carrying guns or
in the united states the police carry
guns you don't have people carrying guns
living with a different reality than
what is our shared reality um uh so i i
didn't feel bad that when we got moved
on to it it's just it was an example of
how dynamic things are facebook um the
moment that i realized facebook needed
help right that it wasn't going to be
able to solve these problems alone like
i needed help to solve these problems
together
was um about a month a little less than
a month after the u.s 2020 election
uh
facebook announced we're dissolving our
civic integrity team
so this is the parent team that i was
part of so i worked on civic
misinformation
under civic integrity
and a little less than a month
afterwards uh they came out and said you
know your work is so important that
we're going to integrate you into all
these other places in the company
and at facebook that's not how reorgs
work right like your team either eats
other teams or your team is eaten by
other teams um
and i don't think i was the only one
that felt that way because the team that
i got moved on to
every single product manager on the team
quit in the same six-week span about six
weeks later not six weeks six months
later
um so i i wasn't the only one that left
about the same time
um but the the reason why i was like oh
my goodness like this is a problem was
facebook's bar for success
was that there wasn't riots for 20 for
the us 2020 election
right we still were facing genocide
problems we still were facing the
algorithms giving the most reach the
most extreme ideas
but facebook was like oh like we passed
this crisis point we don't we don't need
these folks anymore and because they
dissolved civic integrity there was no
one around to form the war room
to turn the safety systems back on
before january 6th
and at 5 pm on eastern time on january
6th
the whole list of safety features so
this is not this is not censorship this
is things like how much should you
amplify live video
right like facebook um regularly has a
problem with people committing suicide
on live video or killing other people on
live video like christ church in new
zealand was filmed on live video
broadcast on live video um you know
the kinds of safety things that were off
at 5 pm on january 6th
were here were things like should you
amplify video live video 850 times
like more than it would have earned
otherwise probably not if you can't
control it
but because they got rid of civic
integrity no one was there to actually
you know pull you know
raise the red flag and say we need to
act
so when did is that when you that was an
insight yeah and um i it took me a while
to think through like how to do it
um because i you know um you know i was
working on counter espionage by that
point like i said you get thrown around
different spots um the last eight months
i was at
at um
facebook i worked within the threat
intelligence work
and um so i'm working on counter
espionage so i was thinking
very carefully as a data scientist like
how would i
look for myself if i were like trying to
find someone who was doing this and so
it took me a long time to figure out a
plan that i felt confident
and were you able to seek advice from
anyone or not because what you're
working on is so confidential you're
quite it's actually quite like almost a
solo decision
um
i had had i had had a bunch of time
during 2020 to talk to my parents
because i lived with my parents during
coveted about um on
the things that i was seeing at work and
to talk through like what might i do
and so by the time i decided to act i
had lots of time to become okay with the
idea of acting so the only people i
talked to about in great depth were my
parents
and
i tried to reach out to
um
[Music]
i'm trying to decide whether or not to
name and shame them
i reached out to a large tech advocacy
group which will remain nameless to
protect the guilty
and and told them uh
very early on so
back during the iowa caucuses i i tried
to talk to them about like what i was
seeing
and um
and they
because because back then the
conversation wasn't about how do we fix
the algorithms how do we look at the
product choices that facebook has made
that have caused the most extreme
content to get the most reach because
the only frame of reference at that
point was the frame of reference that
facebook gave
you know they said the only things we
can do to keep people safe are
censorship
that tech advocacy group was not willing
to help me at that time because they're
like well even if the public knew about
these things all they would do is censor
them
and um and so i i
i did have to do it on my own
so you make the decision uh you do it
and then what happens is there a point
where i imagine if it's you're in code
are you working from home at this point
so it's not like you leave the office
for the for the last time yeah
uh what starts to happen after you uh
you know share the information
and
the
so things things stayed very quiet for
quite a long time so it was only
right in the lead-up to
the
uh first article being published at the
wall street journal that my lawyers
started talking to me about like you
know do you want to be publicly like
like you should think really hard about
coming out publicly and you stopped
working for facebook yes yes i stopped
running for facebook back in may yeah
and um and our first article came out in
september
and um the
i
my most people aren't aware of this but
like part of the reason why the
ukrainian whistleblower for trump's
impeachment stayed anonymous
was because his lawyer who happened to
be my lawyer
um sat and called every major media
outlet in the united states over and
over again for weeks saying if this
guy's name leaks and he gets
assassinated because there's people
calling for his death right now
if you out him we're gonna we're gonna
make sure the blood is on your hands
and my lawyer was just really blunt with
me on being like you don't have
that stick like they're gonna hunt for
your identity and guess what facebook
knows your identity like facebook could
out you they could try to discredit all
these all these disclosures by painting
you some really negative light
um and so that late in that summer i had
to make a decision on whether or not to
come out and um based on the information
that i had at the time i decided it was
safer to control
the point at which i entered the public
dialogue
and at that point um what do you find
the public reaction to be were you ready
for the scrutiny that comes with it
um i've had a it's so funny like um i've
been incredibly lucky
like i know how hard it's been for
um like uh for snowden or for reality
winner or like chelsea manning like i
know i know how hard it's been for
people who have have whistleblown on the
federal government
um
there is not that level of
allegiance or goodwill towards facebook
and um i think that's why um like i
don't even get sent mean messages on my
dms
like i always say like i leave my dms
open like if you want to be mean to me
you can i do respond but i usually ask
you could you tell me more um
but people i think it's i i've had a
a very
a very fortunate emergence into the
public line because people have been
very supportive um you mentioned other
whistleblowers and obviously going after
the government i mean in this case
obviously having to leave the country i
know um have you spoken to any other
suppose i mean i wonder if there's any
like a bit of a solidarity club uh when
i when i came out a whole bunch of um
other tech whistleblowers all like
reached out to me on twitter and so that
was that was cute
and um and i i feel like i've had a
chance to
um
pay some of that support forward because
uh the reality is like not all
whistleblowers accept um
like assistance so like i've been very
lucky that um
you know the the legal aid group i work
with
you know they were amazing guides in
terms of supporting me
in being a whistleblower
but there are other whistleblowers who
feel like they have to do it all on
their own
and um i've been grateful that i've also
been able to like coach and support
other whistleblowers and say like
actually
you know we're not superheroes like
we're all humans and like you know
accepting help doesn't mean you're weak
it just means like we all we all need a
little help
um now since obviously you um blew the
whistle on facebook they faced lots of
scrutiny
um and i think lots of negative
publicity um but i think just for the
endless point kind of moving to the
present day i wanted i mean first do you
think facebook have learned any lessons
yet and then i want to ask you about the
online safety bill
so we have seen some changes in facebook
already even without mandated changes so
the digital services act just passed in
europe
and there are many changes that are
going to be coming down the pipeline as
a result of that but even before being
forced to do things like transparency um
facebook has
uh launched some things that show that
they they have listened to at least some
of the criticisms so i'll give an
example
uh
at any point in the last 10 years they
could have released parental controls on
instagram
at any point right people have been
asking for parental controls
forever
and these are things like saying can you
assign a time allowance to your kids
because the reality is the kids that are
most harmed by social media are the ones
that
have a negative relationship with it and
then end up doom scrolling at 2 a.m
3 a.m right where their anxiety
pulls them to engage more but at the
same time the content is making them
more anxious
um time budgets are important for for
kid safety
um they didn't launch those until like
two months ago
like they weren't really parental
controls till then or facebook has made
some efforts to
try to support more languages for its
safety systems like they announced in
december that they were re-architecting
how they did those so they could try to
cover more languages
and
online safety bill currently going
through parliament i've recently
actually had nadine doris on this
podcast the culture secretary who's
leading the legislation um what do you
make of it in terms of i suppose
fairly briefly for our listeners because
obviously it's a very ex wide bill but i
just wondered um what you think is is
good that it's doing and then where you
think it actually is potentially lacking
um
i think one of the places where uh you
know the uk is really establishing a
reputation around is is it it is very
thoughtful about the rights of children
and like safety by design and
uh making sure that that kid more kids
are safer at least online because the
reality is the internet was not designed
for children and right now the people
playing the highest costs at least in
our societies for um
social media are our children
um
some of the places where it's a little
weaker are things like there's a large
focus on content
versus on focusing as much on systems so
the digital services act out of europe
focuses more on you know making sure
there's transparency from day one
so that means uh academics researchers
the regular gain access to data from the
start
the online safety bill says uh you know
we're going to do a two-year period
offcom is going to do a two-year period
where they're going to ask the question
should we have access to data
we've known for 10 years we need access
to data like we we
would never trust an oil company like
let's imagine some kids were sick
downwind from an oil derrick
we would never turn to that oil company
and be like why do you think why do you
think these kids are sick and if they're
like have you seen the clouds in the sky
have you talked to a meteorologist yet
maybe it's maybe it's the clouds no no
no we would send an environmental
scientist out there who would test the
air they would test the soil they would
test the water and they'd come back and
be like no like the oil derrick is like
burning off the stuff and there's a
by-product in it like we when
we wouldn't ask the person committing
the harm to let us know what the
solutions are we would ask our own
questions and we would do our own
research and until we have access to
data
we cannot act independently so
the online safety bill has to move from
saying should we have access to data to
saying how will we have access to data
and instead of it taking two years to
start giving access it should take three
months because the online the digital
service act is going to have data on day
one
starting in january is the data uh
almost uh looking at um how things are
targeted and in that sense that would be
one thing yeah right so it's a huge it's
a it's a promoting it's things like what
content gets the most promotion right uh
where are the biases where are the
biases in the censorship systems right
now we have no idea how these things
work but facebook's own documents say
things like 75 of counter terrorism
content in some languages it's getting
labeled as terrorism content and taken
down
we need transparency to see how these
systems work another place where i think
the bill could be stronger is right now
it's allowing the um
uh
i think it's like this the secretary is
it's allowing a minister an elected
minister to say what content should be
taken down instead of having an
independent having ofcom do it
ofcom is an independent regulator we
don't want to have an elected official
who might have their thumb on the scale
deciding what canon can't be said we
want the independent regulator to have
that role
yeah you mentioned that and i think one
of the criticisms that has been aired in
the spectator but also in parliament is
concerns over legal but harmful and how
that can be interpreted how it could
move and whether actually it could be a
threat to free speech in the sense that
um you could say
if you argue that something could be
harmful but it's not actually illegal
you can start to see how um
well melodine doris was on the um
podcast she was saying as to your point
well actually you know some twitter
pylons would be okay so a twitter pilot
about her would be okay and but at
twitter parliament was racism would not
be okay but i think lots of people think
well in terms of the
legal harmful side you're going to bring
more in i wonder what do you think about
that
i think there's uh
when we look at you know we said before
about the greatest harms to like say
kids a lot of the stuff that is harming
kids is totally legal content right um
one of the things that facebook's own
documents say is you know we like to
think that facebook is a mirror like
when you pull people people say oh
facebook's just showing me what what
what's
um in reality facebook is an amplifier
right you can take a brand new instagram
account with no friends no interests and
search for something like healthy eating
and just click on the content they give
you you know follow the hashtag
suggested and get taken to anarch pro
anorexia content within two weeks
that kind of thing an algorithm that
pushes kids actively from just an
innocuous thing like healthy recipes
to pro-anorexia and self-harm content
because both those things are what
facebook found
we need to make sure there's some space
in there where we can still make sure
that those things get captured and so i
think transparency is a good compliment
where it's one of these things where
right now we don't know what content
they take down or leave up
we should have an ability to see what's
going on and then we can put pressure
and democratic accountability on the
system
and finally rod little writes in this
magazine about his attention span games
like bubble shooter are ruining his
ability to focus he says should we be
more concerned about how much time we
spend on our phones rod joins me now
rod thanks for joining me on spectator
tv in the magazine
in the magazine this week you write
about your attention deficit talk us
through your problem
it's so good to unburden myself to you
uh
i i've just noticed that i've become
a lot lazier in the last 10 15
years
i don't think it's laziness in my part i
think it's
just the way i am and the pragmatic way
of getting along but i've noticed
that uh i take far too long spent far
too much time
online
doing fatuous inane things
talking to idiots
uh delivering platitudes via whatsapp or
or the boomers uh forum facebook
instead of doing stuff which is
intellectually taxing uh and in the end
more rewarding
and um
i i
this this came to this came to my
attention some time ago but then i read
a very good book about it by uh johan
harry uh the journalist uh i'll show it
to you it's here uh i've got it there
you are that you see
i appreciate that plug
yeah i appreciate i appreciate that plug
for his book we will appreciate that
uh plugging a lefty uh it's called
stolen focus
now on why you can't pay attention
anymore and uh it seems to me that he's
got it right i mean i'm not sure that
johan has got
the answer to it uh in the you know it
is on the on the far left and believes
that the best way to deal with this is
to abolish capitalism uh and various
other things which and you know stop
global warming uh stop airborne
pollution and all this kind of stuff but
where he is brilliant is on the analysis
of where we are now with our attention
deficit disorders uh uh which is which
seems to be a kind of universal thing
and what it what
the point that he makes is that it's not
simply
about self-discipline now i think he
underplays
uh
the the role of self-discipline a little
but he's very compelling on the degree
to which
the the tech firms uh
compel us
to be on their sites
you know and also of course when i look
at my daughter uh when we say to her why
are you on your phone all the time well
all her work is now on her phone
at school
so so she is tied to that phone uh and
it's i think it's a real problem
are they compelling us to be on their
websites or do we just enjoy it a bit
too much i mean i find that if i move
the apps on my phone around and sort of
hide them from myself i can be off them
for quite some time um you know it's not
that i need to be on them but i i like
being on them so i have to make a
conscious effort not to be
yeah you might be kidding yourself
though much as i was you know
said for example
you know uh when i when i get up in the
morning i do a couple of crosswords two
or three crosswords uh the cryptic kind
and i tell myself that i'm doing this
because it it
it enlivens my brain gets my brain
working properly uh halfway through a
piece i'll stop and play some fatuous
games such as bubble shooter or luxor
and and i tell myself that i need to do
this because i need a bit of breathing
space to clear my mind so that it's
ready for the next part it's all
bollocks you know it's it's and then
there's facebook you see an awful lot of
the stuff an awful lot of the reason we
return to these things is because it
because it gives us
a chemical satisfaction
so almost everything i do online when i
do it is i am rewarded
um
by
people telling me how brilliant or
adorable i am now i know obviously that
i am brilliant and adorable but it is
very nice to be told it uh repeatedly
and you get told that by hearts or
upticks on facebook
and then when i do a wordle in
in
when i do wordle in three goes
and it tells me how impressive i am
uh when i complete
a bubble shooter in a
it tells me wow rod
you've totally rock and my serotonin
levels increase
i feel a sense of well-being uh and a
kind of messianic fervor for myself
and that's what that's one of the ways
in which the internet companies get you
uh get you hooked it is a chemical
addiction you know you crave this
you actually need more affirmations in
your daily life from real people or do
you actually prefer to hear them from
your app and from some
some voice coming from your phone
i think everybody
needs uh affirmation i don't think i'm
especially needy perhaps i am
uh but i think everybody needs that and
i think that the high-tech companies
play on it because
uh it's something which draws you back
and draws you back and yelling is very
good as well on the various other stuff
they do which i don't really want to go
into because it's complex on the way in
which these high-tech firms
pull you back in but you know just to
give you an example of what's happened
to us
our attention span
it's it's a great story this our
attention span in 2000 in the year 2000
was 12 seconds
okay which isn't great it's now
8.25 seconds or at least
um that was 20 20 19. so it's probably
gone down from there as well we now have
a shorter attention span than a goldfish
similarly
you can look at twitter trends
and how long people take on twitter
trends and how long those trends last
so for example
in 2013 uh the average twitter trend
would last 17.5 hours these days it
lasts 11.9 hours
so
lots of things are happening one of the
things that's happening is we're getting
more and more information into us more
and more content
and therefore we spend we we
spend less time on each bit of content
if you see what i mean because there's
so much of it
but the other thing is that
and this is the thing which i find
the most debilitating and the most
debilitating for our culture is of
course
uh everything is truncated online
into the sort of conversations you might
have on whatsapp tick tock
or twitter
in that they are very very very brief
conversations there is no room for
nuance
there is no room for context
and so
you never get a deep understanding of
things and other people when you say
things misunderstand them you know this
has happened to me plenty of times
the the most
salutary to me was
when i wrote a piece
satirizing the government's
agonies over when it should call an
election to make sure that the right
kind of people would be there to vote
for it
the satire included
um
a line about doing it on a day when
muslims couldn't vote
for religious reasons
uh and this
went berserk in this twittersphere lidl
says that
muslims shouldn't be
muslims shouldn't be allowed to vote
when i was saying in a sense precisely
the opposite of that because i was being
satirical and if you'd have the rest of
the priesthood context you'd have
understood that so you know it it's it
it hurts understanding it stops us
understanding things
rod i think um a lot of our watchers and
readers will want to know if you
struggle with your attention span when
you're writing do you find that to be a
fluid process in which you can sit down
and bash a whole column out
or do you find that you're distracted
even when you're writing your columns no
i'm lucky enough actually when i'm
writing my column it's not too bad
uh i i just get through it because i
love writing
uh and i find it reasonably easy
to write
uh
so no that's not a problem but once the
columns written
how other people take it is a problem
you know
that really is a problem and it's a
problem for our political discourse
generally as well i think
rod thanks for joining spectator tv
that's it for this week once again we're
delighted that can't accord genuity
wealth management is sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes can accord will provide
the expertise you need to build your
wealth with confidence you can visit can
do wealth dot com to find out more and
don't forget to subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel just click
the subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode thanks
again for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you